[Música]
sean todos bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
el más reciente informe del grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático expone que es
indiscutible que la actividad humana es
responsable por el calentamiento global
y añade que la temperatura del planeta
podría cruzar el nivel del 1.5 grados de
calentamiento en los próximos 20 años
para analizar este documento calificado
de código rojo para la humanidad por la
onu conectamos con rodrigo perpetua el
secretario ejecutivo de iclei américa
del sur la principal asociación global
de gobiernos locales y también sus
nacionales dedicados al desarrollo
urbano sostenible gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros rodrigo el informe señala
la responsabilidad de la humanidad en el
calentamiento global qué medidas
efectivas se pueden tomar para combatir
esta crisis
cuando raúl bien el mensaje es muy claro
o sea la novedad del informe es que se
comprueba que la acción humana es
responsable por este cargamento por por
esta crisis climática y por supuesto una
entidad con mick ley tiene la
responsabilidad de llamar la atención de
las autoridades locales para este hecho
y hacer con que ellas puedan primero
comprometerse con esta agenda climática
en dos perspectivas mitigar las
emisiones de gases del efecto
invernadero por una parte y también
trabajar para minimizar el impacto
prevenir su territorio para el impacto
de los eventos extremos de la naturaleza
que van a intensificarse a lo largo de
los próximos años ahora rodrigo desde su
conocimiento que puede y debe hacerse en
el desarrollo de los centros urbanos
para mejorar la sostenibilidad como
poder aprovechar la energía solar y el
agua de lluvia por ejemplo
si esta es la clave porque en las
autoridades locales tienen la
gobernabilidad ante algunos temas que
son muy importantes para enfrentar esta
crisis climática 1 movilidad urbana ahí
está el transporte público como un
factor de emisión de gases del efecto
invernadero muy grave entonces cambiar
las dinámicas de movilidad en el
territorio de las ciudades para
priorizar modales de movilidad activa
bicis caminadas y mezclar eso con los
modales de movilidad menos impactantes
por otra parte trabajar también en
cuestiones de uso del suelo por lo tanto
criterios para edificación y
construcción en las ciudades criterios
para licenciar actividades productivas
criterios para compras públicas y
construcción de infraestructura tiene
que revisarse con criterios también de
sustentabilidad por otra parte las
autoridades locales pueden trabajar en
la de la población para que se
comprendan como esta crisis climática y
cada vez más amenazar a la ciudadanía
ahora muchos piensan que el cuidado del
medio ambiente puede ir en contra de la
economía es decir que actuar a favor del
medio ambiente perjudica numerosas
actividades económicas este esto cierto
por el contrario es la oportunidad para
el surgimiento de nuevas empresas y
también emprendimientos claro esta es
una falacia o sea no a más como pensar
en el desarrollo económico sí que este
desarrollo se pase en armonía con el
medio ambiente y este es el desafío que
tenemos es cambiar las dinámicas de
producción por una parte de consumo por
otra parte y eso se hace con una grande
alianza entre poder público en todos sus
niveles la sociedad civil organizada las
entidades representativas del sector
privado y por supuesto la ciudadanía
es posible lograr un enfoque global para
enfrentar esta problemática realmente
los líderes mundiales pueden unirse en
una estrategia conjunta más allá de sus
intereses económicos particulares muy
rápidamente por favor rodrigo no
solamente es posible como necesario la
cuestión climática es hoy una cuestión
de seguridad internacional y por lo
tanto se requiere que en la próxima 426
la reunión de los jefes de estado que
será en noviembre se haga un compromiso
muy fuerte para elevar la ambición de
enfrentamiento a esta crisis climática
rodrigo y también entender que en
nuestra casa hay que cuidarla y hay que
tomar ya cartas en el asunto por todos
estos cambios y tragedias ambientales
que estamos viendo y viviendo en la
actualidad rodrigo gracias por su tiempo
y por estar aquí con nosotros en cinco
minutos con en france 24 a ustedes a mí
gracias continúa con nosotros porque hay
mucho más para ver aquí en nuestro canal
[Música]